pete heggseth is over here at the maps
let's take a look at what pete has drawn
up for us pete heggseth
things are changing rapidly as you're
talking about tonight so this is a map
from yesterday march 2nd you look at the
areas controlled by the russians just
move one day forward not a lot of
movement on the map but the air strikes
continue and increasingly indiscriminate
one detail that maybe has not gotten as
much coverage as it could zilinski
asking civilians to take up arms could
be a rationalization a twisted one a
justified one that putin could take to
target civilian areas saying well you're
combatants now and we're seeing that in
places uh like maripool and kharkiv
which are encircled and being targeted
tonight but that nuclear plant that you
just mentioned jesse in the south of
ukraine uh and it is part of the
encroachment the the the offensive
advantage that you that the russians
have shown in the last 24 hours
especially prominent in the southern
part of the country we know about all
the axes of advance in the north kharkiv
in the disputed areas in the east and
through the south but in the south
they've they've made they've made
advances in ways that we haven't seen in
the north and there's a reason for that
jesse
part of the reason for that let me clear
the map and clear the scanner
part of the reason for that
is that down in the south you see that
uh we're gonna advance it one more time
crimea which we know was taken by by the
russians for uh eight years ago
they've got significant basing down
there they've got the ability to project
troops in the north they had military
exercises in belarus and elsewhere where
they can't project the logistics and as
someone who's been in these types of
situations if you don't have the food
the fuel and the logistics to move it
forward things will stall and they've
stalled quickly but in the south they
have not and they've moved they're
moving toward odessa taking over karasan
the flag of ukraine still flies over
karasana may give you a sense even
though it's been taken over by the
russians vladimir putin may not want to
occupy may want to pacify and bypass
which we've seen in curacao then of
course as you've talked about all night
the land bridge to the additional
portion in the east could give them a
logistical advantage they want to as
you've talked about control the black
sea and these bombardments of these
populations likely meant to create an
opportunity where they can punch through
and where do they want to punch through
to they want to punch through to the
ultimate prize which where there have
been some developments when we showed
march 2nd to march 3rd jesse one of the
things that has changed is is
significant uh movement just to the to
the east of kiev where they've they've
been now these forces are minimal i
don't want to overplay that they're not
as the large tank columns that we see
stalled outside the capital and some
moving on the east but if they can move
from the south as this is an anaconda
python type approach we know about
russia has not been able to completely
control the skies but they still have
overwhelming combat power and
capabilities what i'm hearing i'm
hearing the same thing general king
talked about they're deploying troops
likely from across russia as far as far
off as the pacific which means they are
all in on this which is precisely what
emmanuel macron said today they're in uh
and they're not backing off so do me a
favor pull out wide to the map so we
could see the whole country for us
because i think i've noticed something
and you've probably seen the same thing
if they come up from the east and they
come up from the south and they come
down from the north on the eastern
section of this country
at some point the ukrainian forces are
just going to get swallowed it's exactly
right they're going to get they're going
to be completely surrounded on all sides
as they move up the river from the south
to the north and they're going to be
surrounded and then it's just going to
be
it's going to be ungodly that's part of
the strategy jesse this at the beginning
of the conflict 60 of ukraine's forces
were in the east they've been fighting a
war there for eight years what
percentage of those have moved west to
reinforce we're not quite sure but what
the russians want to do is cut it in
half and if they cut it in half they
can't flee west and they're just going
to be strangled like an anaconda and you
can also cut this off which
which stops the ability to reinforce
from the west as well right i mean you
can see it playing out in real time
thanks so much pete heg seth at the map
thank you jesse that was great hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else